move this hot pilot you can do this
Carrie become a much smarter person now
you're not a pilot
are you yes lesson learned if you ever
want to piss off a whole government just
take out 92 star cruisers in a small
family-owned Mexican restaurant sorry
Guadalupe hey everybody its charlie
oh my double crap olan Rogers got
himself a TV show if you don't know
what's going on Owen Rogers very
prominent youtuber from a couple of
years ago did an animated pilot called
final space it has now been turned into
a TV show as part of TBS's new sort of
adult animation Adult Swim style
programming block they just dropped the
first episode on television but they put
the first three episodes up on the TBS
app so you can watch ahead if you want
to he was super cool and gave me like
the first six episodes to watch I've
only watched the first couple and it
does get better with each episode so it
starts off a little bit like Duncan
Jones Moon with him by himself in outer
space for this indeterminate amount of
time then you find out how he ended up
there then it winds up being a little
out lost our bravest warriors space
dandy in some classic mainstream sci-fi
like Star Wars so he is doing a
straight-up sci-fi series is not
intended to parody sci-fi and the way
that Rick and Morty does they've got a
crazy talent list you probably picked up
on a couple of the more famous voice
actors like David Tennant is doing the
voice of Lord Commander he's sort of the
big bad of the series
[Music]
just like justin roiland on Rick and
Morty doing a couple of the voices
himself olan rogers does the voice of
Gary he also does Beth's assistant here
he's kind of an annoying character but
he sort of fades into the background a
little bit Tom Kenny is the voice of
Hugh the voice of the AI of the ship
good morning Gary day 1818 how about
freaking knows Fred Armisen is the voice
of Kevin this robot that keeps stealing
all of his cookies and that John
DiMaggio plays a couple different voices
like he's the bounty hunter that comes
after moon cake later in the episode but
is also working with avocado and then
he's also the guy who's chasing him when
he steals the diamond at the beginning
of the episode I believe he's also the
infinity guard that Gary steals the
uniform off of in the diner too so this
is just the first episode there are a
couple characters that don't debut till
the second episode Steven Yeun Glen from
Walking Dead is voicing a character you
don't really meet him till the second
episode he's playing little gato the son
of avocado who you learn a little bit
more about by that second episode
so I really do think that Cirie's
benefits from you watching those first
two episodes back-to-back because like I
said it's intended to be adult animation
it airs at 10:30 p.m. on Monday nights
so this is the expectation that it's
gonna be a little more hardcore the
first episode doesn't necessarily
deliver on that the only real wink at
that is the idea that he's completely
failed in the opener for the episode
like he's running out of oxygen he's
dying in space in his spaceship that you
see later in the episode is completely
torn to shreds it seems like what
they're doing because it's like a 10
episode run is that each new episode he
has one minute less of oxygen so in the
first episode he has 9 minutes of oxygen
when you begin in the second episode
it's the same scene but it's like one
minute into the future you have eight
minutes of oxygen so by the time we get
to the finale he'll have run out of
oxygen and hopefully there'll be some
solution by that time there are a couple
of really big sci-fi concepts like time
travel that they don't really get into
in the first episode like you see the
ship fold light which is basically them
folding space and opening a wormhole to
another part of the universe so you
understand how they travel around so
quickly and I don't want to get too deep
into episode 2 just because this is
supposed to be an episode 1 video but
they introduced more sci-fi concepts so
time-travel is a component of the series
they introduced this narrative twist
that explains how Gary can continue to
fail upwards as he says like he's the
Kramer of outer space like he kind of
has a good heart but he does a really
dumb stuff it falls
ass-backwards into success at every turn
so I feel like the first episode did a
good job of just introducing you to the
characters and the animation style and
what the tone of the series is going to
be as well as like the big makeup and
like mooncake is the MacGuffin that
everybody wants to get to turn him into
a weapon it sounds like he's changed the
plot of that original pilot that he did
a couple years ago quite a bit if you
watch that it's basically the same
characters albeit the plot is sped way
up like you actually see Lord Commander
using him to blow stuff up so I'm
assuming some of the basic ideas of that
have held like there's a time-travel
component that you learn about during
that because it's a 10 episode series
now I'm interested to see how many of
those concepts survive to the more
polished version of the show now so like
I said the series
get quite a bit better as you go along
in episodes in speaking of the animation
it actually looks pretty fantastic it
looks way more polished than a lot of
the other animated series that are going
on here open the airlock you are a
prisoner how will I know you won't run a
freak with that if you are not back
aboard the ship in five hours your brain
will go into convulsive spasms and then
explode
probably one of the biggest differences
though between this and say like bravest
warriors or Rick and Morty the other
like really crazy sci-fi animated series
is that it's heavily serialized and even
though I've only seen the first couple
of episodes I'm kind of expecting there
to be you know a couple of one-off
stories that exist by themselves like I
don't know that it'll be entirely
serialized but much more than Rick and
Morty like there are elements of that
running storyline with the Citadel and
evil Morty but you could watch a lot of
Rick and Morty out of order and it
wouldn't completely mess up the
narrative or like bravest warriors which
kind of does the adventure time thing
where the characters learn things that
stick from episode to episode but the
actual action of each episode is
completely different and they don't
always reference stuff that happened the
previous week it's the bravest warriors
I ain't going in there sorry Gail
you should put some time clams on it see
if it wears itself out we gots the book
but if you like some of those other
series I feel like you'll probably enjoy
this and especially you know if you're
really a big fan of David Tennant or
some of these other actors or if you
just really like olan Rogers stuff it's
so awesome to see a youtuber hit it big
like this
this is him actually talking to Conan a
little bit about the series itself this
is the clip it's essentially Gary and
avocado get trapped in this oblivion
cube and I like that you're talking like
everybody knows exactly what you're
talking about you know Gary novel kata
you know what I'm talking about
yeah they get traveling there's oblivion
cube and all they're like basically
whatever they think becomes reality and
Gary's obsessed with cookies so like
wouldn't it be cool
olan rogers totally cool dude he
actually contacted me and did say that
it does get crazier with each episode so
like Rick and Morty took a couple
episodes to turn into what it actually
is
you watch that original pilot episode
and it's a really raw compared to some
of the more polished episodes that they
got to later on but if you are wondering
they do tease ideas that they pay off
later so like in the diner that problem
is something that they pick up on during
episode two and like I said there's a
big time-travel twist it's also
connected to that as well so by the time
you get to the end of that second
episode there's still part of that
overarching mystery that they haven't
revealed yet so it'll just continue to
get teased out with the first couple of
episodes but let me know in the comments
if you want me to do weekly episode
videos for this there's a bunch of other
big animated shows premiering this year
there's a Deadpool animated series
that's premiering in May that I'll do
videos for obviously I would do Deadpool
videos this is right down my alley
we have Young Justice that's gonna
premiere at the end of the year so this
is just like one in a long line of
really cool adult animated series that's
dropping but while you wait for
everything click here for that animated
Rick and Morty short that actually
features olan Rogers characters is
actually pretty funny and you can click
here for more Rick and Morty thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]